welcome to this video playing haba from
nowhere probably there's no flag and
let's go for the French to rush yeah and
this move is really getting into fashion
96 its sound pretty decent Wow is there
something else I could play yeah I know
it looks really really boring but I just
want some other position with e 5 97 I
really don't don't know what's going on
I mean especially from the white side
this is a fairly symmetrical position
where blacks a knight on c6 isn't too
great I hope and jam yeah it's um very
very symmetrical and Josh but it's solid
let's see maybe I can press something
out of this
my DS night g3 and h3 okay what about 93
now yeah there's a text of the bishop
and the pawn yeah and here if I take and
play Knight g5 is this something or not
yeah what else I mean if I want to play
for for something here need to do that
Nigeria will probably just retreat and
on Queen h5 play age six minute this is
really not much to put it put it mildly
but if I don't do that it's it's
completely useless so maybe try for that
anyway
yeah I guess it paid off black rosanna
yeah bit of a nothing game so quickly
here but it's still I still upload
because I'd like to quickly explore the
possibilities after Bishop d7 which
looks normal right I wanted to play
Queen to h5 but the comp here we have
the usual thing the computer what's up
Quincy too which is really strong I mean
hey I with the bond and when he from
didn't see that because f5 the screen b3
plan quite quite embarrassing and if you
don't have a five you lose the porn I
was only thinking about this really add
after age 6 I really didn't know what to
do I thought maybe d5 but it it doesn't
seem to lead to much black and even just
move it somewhere here then this yeah
black should be fine here absolutely and
why this isn't well coordinated so what
I played was actually okay but not with
the intention that I that I had after
this I think Bishop d7 is the museum
comp actually wants to give the poor
immediately with this just quite strange
but ok if it's lost anyway but I didn't
sequence to at all after after Bishop
oops we should be sandwich is really the
human move I didn't see that at all it's
no way to to protect it alright thanks
for watching